welcome i'm paul cowling with film
independent
and welcome to this week's coffee talk
uh for those who don't know us film
independent is the non-profit arts
organization based in los angeles
uh responsible for producing the film
independent spirit awards day before the
oscars
and a slew of year-round screenings and
conversations
panels and workshops so you can check us
out at filmingdependent.org membership
is open to everyone
so today we are joined by two
multi-multi-hyphenates
they are producers writers directors
actors uh buddies so
first up he is the writer director of
the highly acclaimed
martha marcy may marlene which won him
best director
sundance film festival film was also
nominated for three spirit awards
including a best first feature
and tons of other critics awards and uh
film festival awards
uh he's as a producer produced films
such as simon killer
james white and christine and his latest
film as writer director is the nest
sorry jude law carricoon which opens in
theaters
sort of opened in theaters as much as it
could in a pandemic
a few weeks ago and debuts
um on vog and about
in november i think so it's great to
have sean durkin with us hey sean
how are you hey how's it going thanks
for having me how are you doing
good not bad good to have you and
joining sean is
his good friend another multi-hyphenate
uh you know him from films such as
21 junk street neighbors the lego movie
now you see me the disaster artist and
last year's best feature winner
at the spirit awards uh if beyonce could
talk
he also wrote and directed his first
feature the rental which came out in the
summer and hit number one
at the box office it's a pleasure to
welcome dave franco hey dave how you
doing
i'm mute your mic dave i'm muted now
thank you for having
up on stage how are you doing yeah we're
uh we're doing all right considering
you know ups and downs but um everyone's
everyone's healthy and safe so
yeah good days and bad days right
totally
yeah well it's good to have you with us
i know you just grabbed your coffee so
i'm gonna grab my coffee the way these
things work is that i'm gonna step off
stage for about half an hour and let
these two
guys talk shop and talk about filmmaking
for about half an hour and then i'll
come back
to take some questions from the audience
there's a q a button at the bottom
of the screen you can use that to submit
your questions and i'll come back in
about half an hour
to filter those out so uh sean
and jay take it away all right thanks
paul
hey john what's up man how's it going
good good um thinking about like the
best way to start this and maybe we
should uh talk about how we met
yeah sure um so as you know i'm
a massive massive fan of your first film
martha marcy mae marlene
and while i was writing my first film
the rental
um that was a huge inspiration for me
and
throughout the process i kept thinking
like how cool would it be if we could
somehow get
sean durkin to be a part of our movie
and one day
i i just tracked down your email and
sent you the script not expecting to
hear back ever
and not only did you get back to me but
luckily you were like
you know what i'm interested in
producing this with you and
yeah it was a dream yeah i um
it's so funny too because i had um i
basically
had thought i was gonna stop producing
uh really
yeah like i had i'd spent so many years
at borderline
uh producing and working other films and
and in the years leading up to
when you contacted me i you know had a
couple of films fall through
and i felt like i just need to put all
of my energy into directing
and not think about producing it all um
just to get get something made again and
um well this is gonna sound like i'm
fishing for compliments but what i guess
what about
what about this project made you want to
produce again
i was gonna say i mean the first thing
was the script i mean it was um
you know i read a lot as a priest ran as
a director and
it just really struck me um and i think
the thing that struck close to home was
its ambition for wanting to break
genre you know it's it's full-blown
slasher movie but it is a
uh also a full-blown relationship drama
uh that gets interrupted by the slasher
film and so
when i was reading it that really
hit close to home because it's always
what i'm trying to do sure he's always
like take a couple of genres and or use
elements of genre to enhance something
else
and so it just felt really truthful
really good really exciting
and then yeah and then you know sat with
you and joe and
just felt like a good mix and then well
what i'll what i'll say
is that you you you become
somewhat of a mentor to me um through
this process
uh and the best kind of mentor where
you never you never would tell me what
to do you would more
just kind of gently guide me in the
right direction and let me figure it out
for
myself i don't i don't ever think i know
like
i don't ever think that there is an
answer you know i think it's like
so much a filmmaking is doing
your own thing and following your own
instinct right and
and i don't think anyone can tell you
what
or what's best like you as the filmmaker
you're
you're the one who knows and and you're
the one who follows that instinct
and has to has to follow that instinct
and i think
the thing that i saw from the very
beginning of the script was
was that you know it was like very clear
what you wanted this to be
and so in a way i felt my job was just
to
support you in seeing that through fully
right well i'll say i think i mean going
off of that like i think the main thing
that you did for me
was you know your confidence in me
almost was the most important thing
because i respect
you so much that i was like if this guy
believes me
i could do anything and that was
invaluable
and i guess i'm curious like if you've
had
mentors throughout the year or anyone
you really turn to creatively and then
i'd love to kind of get into details of
what you did for me specifically yeah
yeah i mean
i so so when uh josh antonio and i
started borderline
um i mean the whole the whole idea was
based around supporting each other right
so
that was the other thing about this it
was sort of easy to slot in because i've
been doing this forever i've been
helping my partners make first features
and then made films for other
first-time filmmakers um and so
we set up our company with this idea
that we were going to support each other
to do
whatever it is that the director wanted
to do and we were going to make it
first highest quality for as low budget
as possible
and just um help the director
see their vision and make the film so
that at the end of the day they would
have a film their first film would be
everything they wanted to be in and none
of us could turn back and say oh i wish
i could have done that or i could have
done that
yeah and so there was a real camaraderie
and support system in that and i think
that's where
you know where it really formed and and
and especially with
um you know learning from making
like early on with antonio um campos i
you know i was a cinematographer
and and producer you know i shot his
short film so like i got to pick up
things from him
about directing and working with actors
so
we very much had this um
this team but then beyond that um
i had a couple of great mentors uh
was a was a huge uh support for me
who said that more time you cut out ted
hope got it got it
um he was an ep on on martha
and um just
sh always like sort of offered me that
same kind of support
and encouragement you know asked
questions of it and and pushed it but
was always
there to support the movie i wanted to
make end of the day was there anything
specific that you can remember
that like you almost take with you now
for every movie
no not really i think it was just it was
just uh you know the environment
i'd set up with josh and antonio to have
ted hope come into that
and uh so much more experience
and uh wisdom and and to just
you know enhance billy um
was really great and a lot and um
and then the other person too is susan
shotmaker who's my casting director
um i i worked for her as an assistant
for years
and so i got to be in rooms with great
directors
working on movies and just being behind
the camera running camera and
so it got to be in room with you know
terrible directors who were just uh
you know like not very nice to actors
and i could see
actors lose confidence in a room and so
that time with susan where she really
sort of helped me get on my feet so to
speak
um right i mean it kind of makes sense
that you're
really close to your casting director
too because
just thinking about both of your films
you know with martha
elizabeth olsen was relatively unknown
at the time yeah
and then looking at the nest you know
you have these young actors
who i think you said maybe the girl had
never acted before
yeah she she's uh i think this is her
first film she she was in school
um right she graduated from school i
think and so yeah it's these it's these
people who
um you know i i assume you and your
casting director are kind of
just looking everywhere and just trying
to find the best person for the part as
opposed to
trying to find a person with value or or
whatnot yeah
yeah i mean that's always a balance
isn't it i mean it's it's
like how to find the
the best people for the role who can you
know and
and balancing that with people who can
get the film made um
but i really lean on my casting director
uh susan
and then in england uh beige uh
have amazing relationships with actors
and they're always just thinking a
little differently
um and i really trust them and they
always bring me a few people
you know sometimes i'll do water
searches but i really just trust them to
do what they do
and um and then
it's like an instinct thing i trust them
and then
show us the actors they bring and yeah
yeah
we have a really good thing there well
to turn it turn it around on you
i mean you you you gave me a couple of
things that i will take with me
um on every movie uh one of them was
you encouraged me to uh do a table read
with
just me and the actors before we started
filming and
the purpose was so we could go through
each scene
and basically have the actors identify
any lines of dialogue
or even any single words that felt false
to them
and so what it did was you know
immediately they could start to put it
in their own words and then they could
start to kind of take ownership over
these characters
before we got on set and so by the time
we're on set it's like we've already
talked through all this stuff we're all
on the same page now
and it seems like an obvious thing to do
but it was like
it was so helpful yeah i i i
i find that like i believe in a sort of
like handoff that happens right like
when you
hand to an actor i always say like these
are your words now like it doesn't feel
comfortable
in your mouth don't you know like let's
change it and i think
i don't know i i just think it's a great
like collaborative way to start
is um is that
you know is that openness yeah and i
imagine you know there's got to be
certain directors though who are very
precious with their words if they're
also writing the scripts
uh and i i was curious how i would be
and immediately i was the opposite where
you know i think the main thing i
learned is that when i got to set
most days i would be going through the
scenes over and over and i'd be like you
know what i overwrote this we don't know
let's just like get down to like the
basics and yeah
i yeah i always find that right like
like
i always just like overwrite and then
just pull away
step by step and even in the editing
right like
so much of the other thing was just
like speaking of another thing that you
gave me in the edit was
um a really smart thing is at one point
i think when we were we were getting
closer to the end of the edit
uh you asked me you're like are there
any scenes when you're watching it
through you know you've watched it a
hundred times now are there any scenes
where you find your mind drifting and
i really started to think about i'm like
yeah there's these two scenes where
every time i just kind of
check out and then we kind of dove into
those scenes
and i think really kind of slashed them
down
and made them to the point where now i
got excited to watch them
yeah it's such a it's such a like
gut-wrenching part of it where like i
feel like something stays in an edit for
so long because
you need it right you're like oh i need
this
because of this and because of this and
you have these things but then
when you watch it i'm just like you know
there's stuff i watched on this
thing over and it's like that that that
uh
that period of like intellectualizing
versus having
the emotional reaction sure that's like
all the way through the process
to um a really difficult
thing to to navigate
i i'd be curious i'd be curious to know
just with your second film compared to
your first um
a couple of things like you know because
your first feature was so
well regarded did you feel more pressure
going into your second
film and uh you know now that the
film has come out do people compare it
to your first film and is that annoying
and just kind of yeah say what you will
yeah i
i didn't you know i didn't really feel
pressure because
you know the other thing is i i made
this this mini series in england that
was
four hours long i directed the whole
thing and it was an
epic undertaking and um
so i i didn't really think about like oh
i haven't done my second feature yet
because i've done this
and we shot it the same as a film we it
wasn't broken into episodes we shot it
consist
consecutively i mean i felt very much
uh like making a movie um
and so when when when going into this
i didn't think too much about it being a
second film and really it wasn't until
the film was done and it was going to
premiere and
and starting to do press that all the
questions about a second
film come out and so um
it's it is a weird notion and a pressure
that comes with it and the comparison
that comes with it
but i just tried to ignore it because i
just always try to be
just completely focused on the work
itself and completely focused on the
thing and making the thing
that's in front of you
what gave you like what were you doing
before martha like what what made you so
confident going into
that to make a movie just so just solid
i don't know i mean i i don't i don't
know that i was confident in it i
i mean i i i was producing a lot right
so like i
i produced a couple of movies and
um you know it sort of gathered that
experience of
of just and then but you know what i
would say like
the sunday i i was lucky enough to do
the sundance lab
and i think i can't imagine where i
would have been without that
without that experience of doing the
writer's lab and
why do you say that well
i think i had very myself as a writer
like i
i wrote so many i got so so before i
went to film school i
i i went to another school and i was a
part of
what i was gonna major in was writing
and fiction i just
would write short stories and just never
got a reaction i mean
you know my teacher was very sweet but
she'd be like
you know so and then when i got to and
when i got to the
nyu i i writing short scripts and
it was like nothing worked it was so
much stuff that i just never got a
response from so i almost like
had really um i had i had no
confidence in writing and so when the
script for martha got accepted to the
lab it was like oh maybe i can
since it was just a you know positive
reinforcement and then the process
itself
um the process itself really
just you know it was tough and you get a
lot of tough feedback but it was
it was good tough it was just
questioning yourself and it
and i think being forced to ask
questions of yourself makes you stronger
in what you believe sure
yeah yeah i i feel like i had
um a unique kind of
first experience as a director for for a
few reasons like
uh i've been i've been wanting to direct
the future for a long time
uh i i started maybe a decade ago
directing these
these short films for the website funny
or die
um and i think the reason it took me so
long to to jump to a feature was
you know candidly i was a little bit
nervous just because i knew that there
would be
this kind of spotlight on me where
everyone was would be like you know
let's see what this fucker thinks he can
do
and uh and so
i think the reason i chose this one as
my first my first feature was
um after after writing the script and
kind of sitting with it for a while i
was like you know what
i know this thing better than anyone
else and i finally just
felt confident and all the nerves when
it went away and then what happened was
when i stepped on set that first day uh
i realized
i i knew a lot more than i thought i did
because i've been on so many sets as an
actor
and it just made me think about how a
lot of first-time directors when
they're stepping on set that first date
that might be their first time on any
set
ever and so they're learning just about
the dynamics between the crew
and just kind of how things work on a
basic level and so i felt like i was
able to skip a lot of steps because of
that and it just kind of gave me
immediate uh confidence yeah yeah i mean
i i was going to ask if you um i mean
first
of all like like
it's it's an incredible film but it is
like an absolutely astonishing first
feature and
and and it is so assured and
i remember when we were um when we were
getting dailies for the first time i
remember
like joe had got caught up on
uh he got caught up on some dailies and
he text he texted us and
he was like this is so good he's like
this is intimidating good how
how is this so good but i felt like i
felt like it was it was really
incredible to watch like uh
for you know those first dailies coming
in like they just
felt so well directed right away i mean
what i wanted to ask you what do you
have any experiences that you drew upon
from
having all those years you know on set
as an actor and
good or bad experiences that you drew on
should direct
right it's a good question um i think
i think the people that i drew the most
from
were seth rogen and his crew
in the sense that they just create a
very comfortable environment on set
where
they really um they really encourage
everyone to speak up and voice their
opinions if they think it can help the
film in any way
and it just creates this this safe space
where everyone feels included and so it
just really does feel like a nice
collaboration and so i really tried
to bring that energy to mine and
i think the smartest thing i did aside
from bringing you on as a producer
is uh i i really
vetted the crew in like a very extensive
way where i wanted
multiple glowing reviews about each
person before i kind of brought them on
and it was like it was a long
arduous process but in the end i was
just surrounded by
all these really talented people but in
addition to that like
i i wanted people who were going to be
very just nice people who were going to
work their asses off because as a
first-timer i just
needed those types of people who
just the movie was their number one
priority as opposed to some people who
have maybe been around a while
who maybe just see it more as a job and
they just want to get through the day
and get home
yeah i agree i mean i think that's
that's for me it's the only way to make
a movie i mean it doesn't get to happen
every time
but as much as you can control that i
agree i think
creating an environment where everyone
is there
cares about it as much as as much as you
do
yeah uh it's it's that emotional
investment
it just creates a family it creates a
team
and it's like it's the support system
you need you know to know that
everyone's passionate
yeah it reminds me of something else you
you would you would tell me throughout
the process too
is um you would say that directed could
be very lonely
and i think i know what you mean by that
but you want to kind of talk about that
yeah i i um
yeah it's funny because i've like like
i've had experiences of just like
great producers you know great support
great emotional support
uh great editors you know like all of
the
kind of intimate relationships you have
along the way have all been
really great but i think the the sort of
loneliness of being a director can
actually be a result of that when
uh i find there's moments along the way
where i have
you know maybe producers who i
absolutely love and respect or
you know editor or something or someone
in and
something is is going you know we're
exploring a note or going somewhere and
it feels right and everyone
thinks it's right but there's something
that i feel in my gut
that just isn't necessarily where i want
to go with it
sure and so it can be very confusing
when everyone around you
is saying like oh yeah let's do this
let's try this let's go there and you
just
have this red you know red light going
off in your head and you don't know why
and at the end of the day it's as
i believe being a director is following
your gut and and when that
when your gut is telling you that's not
right even though everyone you trust is
saying it is
that can be very lonely and very
difficult and you you can end up making
some decisions that go against
you know people you completely respect
and trust and that's really
challenging i have a i have a very dumb
example of that
uh so do you remember
okay so there's a dog in in the rental
and we found this
we found this cute french bulldog and
the dog's name in real life is chunk
and i was like oh i love that name it
was like this big
chunky bulldog french bulldog and i also
was thinking
uh it's a it's an homage to the goonies
which is one of my favorite movies
growing up and we're we're shooting our
movie on the oregon coast just like the
goonies did this is perfect this is
kismet
and then i realized that there's this
long
sequence in the film where the dog goes
missing
and all the characters are yelling out
for the dog and i realize all the
characters during the what's supposed to
be this tent sequence are going to be
going
chunk i was like
hmm is this going to undermine the
tension
and all the actors and the ad and
everyone was like
no no chuck's so good you got to keep it
how could you not keep it
and then i remember i texted you and i
was like dude what do you think of this
and you're like
no no no no wrong reference wrong moment
[Laughter]
and i swear to god it got to the point
where the actors when i told them i was
like you guys
the dogs gonna be named reggie they were
so upset
that um they were like no no let us
audition
yelling for chunk in like a various real
way
uh but i i totally understand what you
what you're saying where
yeah it's um it's it's amazing to be in
a position where you do
have kind of the final say but at the
same time
um it is scary too when
like you said all these people around
you who you do trust are saying
something else that you need to make
that decision and your gut's telling me
ah i don't agree with what they're
saying yeah and
also like it's such an emotional process
like i certainly find that i
just doubt myself all the way through so
like i can be very confident clear and
know what i want to be
now i'll get there in the end but
process like
there's just you know low points where
you come home and you're just like what
is this this is nothing i don't know
what i've done here and there's
so many months of that and so especially
when you're at that low
phase of not understanding what it is
you're making or you've lost touch with
what you started out or whatever that
whatever that part of the process you're
in
like that that becomes even even
trickier so you don't
like i know that i don't have that like
confidence all the time
so i have to sort of get in touch with
that confidence but but in the end like
i always
i always know and i look back and say
okay i did everything exactly as i
wanted and
the other thing is like having the right
people to support that too the other
thing
i'm very lucky in in the situations i've
been in where
everyone is the people i work with have
my back
even if we have a slightly different
idea definitely definitely
not critical yeah going off of that i i
feel like i got pretty lucky too
because um my wife was in the movie
and so at the end of the day i would go
home to her
and there were many moments where i
started to doubt myself and i would get
in my head
and she was always there to just kind of
build me up in the right ways and remind
me we were doing good work
in in a way that no one else really
could you know she knows me better than
anyone
and when she says something i believe it
and
it was i i honestly don't think i could
have done it without her
yeah um hey i wanted to ask you now that
you've been through
finish your feature first feature you've
released it
um you know done the whole the whole
thing
do you uh do you have a favorite part
favorite part of the process yeah um
i think my favorite part was production
honestly like
i feel like we really did our homework
um in a way where when we finally showed
up on set
we just had everything in place where we
could just be loose and have fun with it
but
i think it might be more interesting
actually to talk about my least favorite
parts uh
yeah sure so no one really prepared me
for
pre-production uh and what a shit
you know something goes wrong every
single day
i remember one of our i remember very
well one of our
actors had to drop out of the film like
a week before we started
and we have a very small cast and so it
was um it was very
it was a big deal and uh it got to the
point though where so many things were
going wrong
and falling apart that i just had to
change my mindset
where i was like you know what i'm going
to expect the worst
so that when that happens i already know
how to pivot and go to plan b
yeah tell me your take on pre-prep
pre-production is the worst i mean
there's so much about it that i love
though i mean i love every part of it i
love every part of the process and
there's a lot of prep that i really love
which is just
um like being in it and thinking about
it but
but there and making decisions like i
really love to um
let like locations
tell me something about the movie right
like so i love searching for the right
place and
and just and and and quite like i can't
always articulate what i need a space
to feel like but i'm very focused on
what a space feels like and so
you know we'll just like keep searching
and searching for the right space
and uh and there's something about like
entering a space
and having it immediately the second you
decide on it
i love that moment of like i no longer
can remember the space
i was imagining because now i only see
this face and
suddenly you know the space is telling
me something about how to shoot
or it's telling me something about the
family or it's telling you know
something something about the character
and so
i really enjoy that and it feels quite
alive
yeah after a certain amount of time
of just getting in and out of vans um
yeah i just get so eager to shoot
there's always that moment of just like
this cannot be going on any longer yes
um
we'll go going off of that location the
locations thing
uh in our script you know there's
there's um
there's like a basement that there's
supposed to be a basement that they go
into a couple times
and we got to the house and we were
asking the homeowner we were like you
guys have a basement of any store and he
was like no
and we were like okay maybe we'll just
have to go to another location for that
and he's like you know what but we do
have this other thing let me show you
and he took us
outside and under the house and there
was this
weird little wooden door that went like
three levels under the house to the
creepiest space you've ever seen in your
life and we're like
that'll work so we like we retooled that
whole section we were like
it's not a basement it's this creepy
fucking door deep under the house
yeah it's like one of the great
excitements of making movies it's like
it's so alive and letting just like
being open
something else dictate you know just
like give yourself over to the process
and know what you want and be clear
but also let it breathe let it tell you
something
and follow that and i love i love that
about it
definitely i want to ask you um
something that just popped in my head
do you uh what what's your take on or
feeling about
reviews do you read them tell me
everything that you're
yeah uh
i i was really good at not reading them
for a long time
i used to be read them uh
i'm no longer mission
i'm no longer in the position to not
read them i read them
now um i
yeah it's hard i mean it's hard uh
it's great when they're great and when
they're not great you feel like you're
misunderstood
and that's that's a hard thing to
balance i i'm i'm not obsessive about it
um i stay i'm not on social media so i
stay off all social media
yeah me too um i it's been pretty funny
doing marketing for the nest because the
the marketing team at ifc has been
incredible uh for both of us yeah yeah
they've had to talk me through some very
basic stuff about
social media which has been hilarious
i feel like i'm slightly stuck in
another time but um
yeah i just uh i don't know i try i try
not to take it too much on when it's
good great and
in other words i try to just not think
about it
i mean you've been in a very fortunate
position where
you make incredible movies and so
they're very well reviewed uh
but i i mean the reason i ask it is just
because you know i
i've obviously i've had a lot of movies
um come out over the years
were that i've acted in and there's been
different levels of anxiety when those
movies come out
but it was a whole different thing when
a movie that you directed is coming out
and i remember like a week before it
came out
i was in a pretty good headspace where i
was like you know what i made the movie
i want to make
i love it i hope other people like but
like i can't control how people feel
and then the like the sunday before
it came out that week i just started
spinning
and i was like what's going on with me
and i think it was just
this feeling of like you know working on
this thing
so intimately for two years and
putting it out in the world and it's not
mine anymore and just feeling
more vulnerable and exposed than i've
ever felt in my life
where if people don't like this thing
that means they hate me
and that's a hard thing to take um
but i really you know i leaned on
allison a lot
who was a superhero uh that week
specifically
and i remember talking to you too and
just kind of another thing you did for
me throughout the process was just
being a sounding board where you had
just such a calming presence
which kind of makes me just able to
process everything in a in a real way
um but yeah i mean it's uh it's a scary
thing putting something out in the world
that you've put so much into
you must have also felt added or i mean
i've certainly seen this
before uh being a known actor to to make
the transition i mean that must have
that you must have a lot of pressure
from that right definitely
yeah i mean in in many ways i like
first off like people a lot of people
were very surprised that my first movie
was a horror film because of the movies
that i've been in
as an actor and so just expectations
were
not maybe where they should be and so
people were already grappling with that
they're like whoa wait dave franco's
making a horror film
like all right i don't know how to
process this so like
i remember um there were there were like
test screenings that we did
uh where all people knew about the film
was that like i directed it
and that maybe it took place in the
world of like home sharing
and so people would go into these test
screenings
and we would you know we would get okay
okay scores but then you'd look at the
like
surveys that they filled out after the
fact and one of the questions was
uh do you enjoy horror films and do you
normally seek them out
and 75 percent of the surveys said no
caps and so it was like people came in
expecting one thing from me and then
they get this other thing that they
hate and so we're like guys we can't
take advice from people who
despise the genre um but anyway i
i i think yeah i think expectation of
any sort is really
unfair to a movie i
so i don't read reviews or i try not to
watch
trailers too because i find trailers
just give too much away so when i go
into a movie i want to know as little as
possible and so that's always
people going into my movies they know as
little as possible because yeah
i find that um
you know most most negative reviews
comparisons to something the movie's not
you know it's yeah and i find
i just find comparison and expectation
a difficult part of the process in the
in that sense and like
instead of just going in with an
openness and letting something be
just what it is which which maybe also
is a part of like
my interest in and one of the things
that drew me to your phone was
is is that mixing of genres you know
like
playing with expectation and trying to
do something a little bit different as
opposed to
fully delivering on something people
have seen time and time again
totally totally hey paul hi paul
hey guys how are you sorry to interrupt
i'm not yep uh we have about time
for questions if you're good for that
definitely definitely
uh i actually had a question well well
people are submitting questions use the
q a
button below i had a question for you
both about
location you talked a little bit about
location but picking the right location
that informs
the story um in both um
the rental and martha marti maybelline
and the nest like the house is a key
part of it
um the rental is basically a cabin in
the woods but you didn't pick a cabin in
the woods you went completely opposite
direction you talked a little about
choosing the right house for the right
mood
and we and sean with master marcy mae
marlene there's something about
where sarah paulson and uh dancing live
that should be a comforting place but
it's not
elizabeth olsen's character how how do
you how do you come to those decisions
go for it sean um i
uh yeah with both with both of my movies
uh they're both set in two locations
that
contrast each other so very much it was
about
finding finding that contrast
and so for the nest
to find a house that was um
that is is too big for this family and
um represents uh
jude law's character's ambition and his
dream
how this family falls apart
because they move into it and so space
was very
uh very important to that process and
finding that right thing that's not
you know so big that you lose the
audience as soon as you get there you
have to be able to see the promise in it
but it also has to be
unsettling enough that it sucks you in
and creates atmosphere and so and so
much of what i look for in space is the
atmosphere
and and i find it really hard to
articulate sort of saying before like i
i find
i can say what i want it to be i can
make a list of things we can make a plan
of what we're looking for
but until i step into it and feel that
it's right in my gut
i can't really say anything else about
it like it's just something i feel
and i'll sort of i sort of know it when
i see it it's not that different to
casting
you know it's like i can't you know say
exactly the person that i want to be but
i'll know it when i see them and i need
them
and i treat the location the same way
hey
for yeah for the rental uh the house is
is of course a huge character in the
film and so
we we really uh went up and down the
entire west coast
um looking for the perfect spot and we
we knew that we found it
with this with this house because so it
was on
on the oregon coast in this little town
called banden and it was perfect because
there's so much natural beauty in the
area that would draw people to want to
vacation there so you understand why the
characters are drawn to it
but at the same time there's just
something kind of ominous about the area
too
with with the jagged coastline and the
fog
and the fact that the house really was
in the middle of nowhere like it was
down this
two-mile narrow dirt road through the
woods
uh and as you can imagine like getting
these giant trucks with you the
equipment down there
was a full-on nightmare but it was worth
it because you just you feel the
isolation once you're there
and like sean said it's like it's more
just a guttural feeling where you just
like you're there and it's like this
atmosphere and i remember
uh when we were in prep i stayed at the
house one night and everything changed
once the sun went down where it's like
the house is all these giant windows
and so at night you really do feel like
you're in this fishbowl and you feel
like anyone could be watching you at any
point and i was like oh this is perfect
i
feel terrified right now yeah a lot of
those houses don't have
like curtains or drapes or anything
you're always like in the middle of
nowhere like
who who could be watching yeah and i can
understand why you could understand why
the characters would pick that house
because it's beautiful but yeah the sun
goes down
that's right yeah my one of my one of my
favorite compliments about the movie is
a couple people have been like
i know that's technically a murder house
but i want to stay there like it looks
so inviting
uh question for you sean from jody um
i thought the nest was absolutely
brilliant um as a script supervisor i'm
wondering if you shot
more coverage and decided not to use it
or was your plan all along to stay in
the wider shots
um no there's not
there's not more coverage than what you
see um i
really like to be as specific as
possible when shooting
um and try to limit the amount of shots
usually
two to two per scene sometimes three
um but very rarely more than three um
[Music]
and a part of that is a simplicity i
just
like a simple approach and i and i like
to create an
environment that gives to the actors and
um
where we can really find the scene and
um yeah just just not
not let any uh you know not let the
technical get in the way like i think
you know doing just loads of coverage
just kills
kills the chance to perform and and keep
the freshness in the performance so i
try to stay away from it
unless it's very specific one one quick
compliment i want to give sean
is i love how he shoots
a dinner scene where i think most
directors see a dinner scene coming up
on the
on the call sheet and they're like oh
fuck all right this is going to take all
day we got to get coverage of everyone
and i think all of your dinner scenes
are one shot
and you just position everyone in a way
where you know you're getting all the
emotion you need and you don't need to
see everyone's faces
and you just get through it and you get
and as an audience you you get
everything you need
yeah they're certainly dinner scenes are
certainly challenging i mean
they're like they're really they're
really difficult to figure out
especially
when when i think you don't want to
shoot everyone and and it's just making
those decisions of like
what's the important thing for this
scene so that
you know what to focus on is there
a tip there what about leaving an empty
seat and kind of shooting from
empty seats perspective i've seen
directors who do that
yeah yeah definitely i mean i think it's
you know i always look for whatever the
space is and what the scene's about
so you know um i think the first
did was in in martha there's a
there's sort of marth is at the
the dinner table with her sister and
brother-in-law
i think it was i remembered that taking
forever to figure out
just the simplicity of a single on her
and a two shot on them
became and it and just finding that like
what the emotion of the scene was about
her feeling
alone and then together you know so it's
just like following
whatever the emotional threat is too to
try and figure it out
as questions for you dave uh from arlene
i hope i'm pronouncing that right how
did you conceive the rental
what was your writing process and how
and did your acting experience help with
character developments
so the the idea was
inspired by my own paranoia about the
concept of home sharing and just kind of
thinking about how
the country is as divided as it's ever
been and no one trusts each other yet
we trust staying in the home of a
stranger simply because of a few
positive reviews online
and the reality is you know while we
were filming the movie
there were articles coming out every
week about homeowners who had hidden
cameras in their places
and then on the flip side it's like how
do we know to trust the people we're
renting to
you know what's keeping these what's
keeping them from uh
renting a place making copies of the key
and coming back at a later date and so
it just felt like this world
this fun kind of world to play with that
we could all kind of relate to
um
okay one more time you're giving people
ideas
hopefully not hopefully more just kind
of prepping you to be overly cautious uh
so so the writing process um
it was a little unique in the sense that
uh so i wrote it with joe swanberg
and he lives in chicago and so we we
basically outlined over the phone for a
few months
and then he came out to la two different
weeks
and we just holed up in his uh in his
hotel room and just
basically had we had a timeline we were
just like we have only this time
together we gotta crank it out
and so we got through the first draft
pretty quickly
uh and joe joe's the perfect writing
partner because
he just has no ego he's one of those
guys he'll
throw a million ideas at you and i'll be
like okay that's the one that's the one
i'm gonna let let's let's run with that
and uh it's amazing because i i truly
think it's harder to find a writing
partner to work with than it is to find
a romantic partner almost so i i want to
keep working with joe as long as he'll
let me
um talking of partners can you talk a
little bit about your relationship with
your
producers or um or with your directors
so like
sean when you're you produced a lot of
films what is your relationship with
your directors like and
dave when you you produced zola
genetics of bravo's new film which is
getting a lot of buzz right now
what was your relationship there as a
producer uh
how how do those play out
i mean on set really i mean
my approach to producing is always just
to support
to support whatever the director needs
um
but to understand the movie they want to
make and then do whatever
whatever i can to help them
reach that goal and it's sort of that
simple and just you know
you know over the years every film
that's a little bit different
and requires something different um but
it's
it's just following that very basic
principle
i i have kind of a similar simple answer
of
you know i was on zola pretty early on
but then once janixa came on board
she she has such a strong vision that
you know my job was more just kind of
getting out of the way and just making
sure
as much as i could just to get any
obstacles out of her way and just let
her do her thing because
she she just knew exactly what she
wanted to do and so
it was just like you go do your thing
and let i just want to be a cheerleader
and be as supportive as possible
a question for both of you saeed asks um
are there any tips or key points to
ensure your film
a place in a film festival
make a good one right yeah it's a good
question no and the answer is no
i mean there's you know i mean i i think
being a filmmaker uh
it is it is a a life of excitement and
disappointment
and ups and downs and um i think
if you you have to find something you
want to make and believe in what you're
doing and
and um and fight to get it made and look
back and know you've made the best thing
you can possibly make and beyond that um
you have very little control over what
happens to it but i think
as long as it's you know your process is
about the work and
and creating the work that you love and
believe in
um you know people will respond to that
yeah i 100 agree that it's just like all
you can do
is is try to make the movie that's in
your head and
i i think the best advice i would give
is to almost have no expectations for
the film
because you know i as we were filming
hours i was thinking all right
you know in an ideal world we'll do the
festival route and then we'll see where
it goes
uh and then uh we encountered a
worldwide pandemic before i even had the
chance to do that and
basically we had to just be like all
right what are we doing now
and uh we ended up premiering at a
at a drive-in uh which people told us at
the time they were like no one's ever
had a premiere out of driving before and
it was all scary but in the end
um the kind of mindset that ifc had for
our film was
they were like at the beginning of the
pandemic is when we paired up with them
and they said
we think there's power in picking a date
and sticking to it no matter what
happens whether theaters are open or not
and we what we can do with that is we
can actually build to it like an event
and actually like just like do the right
press for it and just kind of make it
this thing that people are looking
forward to as opposed to a lot of these
kind of bigger movies that have had to
move
so frequently and it's and it's hard to
kind of do press for those when you
don't know when the movie is going to
come out and so
uh i feel very lucky that um i paired
with ifc
and that we kind of went down the path
we did because as a smaller film we
ended up getting
um maybe a lot more attention than we
would have in during normal times
and uh yeah just uh that's a long way of
saying uh
just get rid of your expectations and
just kind of like go with the flaw
um when ifc pitched um drive-ins as
a venue what was your feeling about that
in your creative team your producing
team
i mean it's you know it sounded fun like
there's some there's there's definitely
like fun nostalgia
connected to drive-ins um
and i felt lucky that the movie actually
kind of catered to that environment and
that type of audience
where some movies just don't maybe play
as well
at a drive-in for for whatever reason
but i think horror films in general
um they fit nicely into into that venue
uh but yeah again i just was like let's
see what happens
i trust you guys let's just try to push
this thing as much as we can and
um it ended up being like uh these
driving screenings ended up being really
fun
uh question for you sean from robert
curious to know if there are any updates
on the von erich
film well thanks for asking
um i'm working on it i'm working on it i
mean
you know the the the thing that's tough
right now is
that um you know anything shooting with
big crowds
becomes more difficult to make so
that's a whole added uh you know that's
that's
a whole added thing to to try and figure
out how to overcome so
uh for a film that deals with wrestling
you know it makes it even more difficult
right now than it would have been anyway
so um but i'm i'm actively working on it
so
i'll see question for you today from
saeed uh
same side maybe uh question um question
about acting or directing what you say
you love the most
i like i like the idea of bouncing back
and forth but i i will say
that i don't think i've ever been as
comfortable as i was
um on the set of the rental and i've
been trying to kind of think about that
and maybe part of it is because i had a
say
in every per you know i i was able to
kind of choose every person who was
surrounding me and so i would just had
all these people who i really
loved and respected um but
but i do like the idea of jumping back
and forth it's nice to kind of
i guess flex different muscles is there
a reason you deliberately didn't cast
yourself
in the film uh yeah kinda i mean
when when i first started writing the
scripts i was i was sort of thinking all
right maybe i'll play
the role of josh that ultimately went to
jeremy allen white
and then when i decided to direct it i
just thought it would be smarter to
focus on my responsibilities behind the
camera especially as a first timer and
i'm really glad it worked out the way it
did because
jeremy allen white is such an incredible
actor and he he brought things to the
character that weren't on the page
that i probably wouldn't have even
thought of and so uh it played out the
way it was supposed
um someone has actually preempted my
question here jeremy
uh for both of you um directing good or
bad directing tips
for someone who's been on both sides of
the camera dave but
for you as well sure like first time
director tips especially directing
actors
you're obviously an advantage today to
know what their headspace is like but
for people who haven't been in the
actor's shoes what
tips could you give first-time directors
for communicating with your actors
yeah it's it's it's interesting i mean i
i guess the thing i would say
that i actually had a really great time
with was
just identifying how each actor worked
because everyone works differently and
for example
one of one of my actors um
would get very existential and they they
wanted to talk about
one word of dialogue and we get into it
for like 30 minutes and what it means
and what it like how it reflects their
like
their history of the character and i was
like let's do it let's get in it
and then there was another actor who
barely said a word he
he just kind of came prepared uh
knew what was going on and whenever he
did
have a question i was always like yeah
what what is it because he just usually
didn't and when he did have a question i
knew it was gonna be super smart
um but yeah it's really just kind of
not treating everyone the same because
no one's the same
and um yeah listen
so yeah i agree so the olivier quote
isn't it laurence olivier
said acting is just remembering your
lines not bumping into the furniture
yeah i mean i agree dave like it it's
that's my approach to this um
with each actor learn how
they work what they want their process
to be and be there for them and the
other the other thing
the most important thing i think you can
do as a director is be comfortable
saying i don't know
i think um you have to
you don't always have to have the answer
and
uh it can be things can go really wrong
when you
think you do and you pretend you do um
but just be confident
yeah i don't know and and you know i'll
figure it out figure it out
we'll do it together and and lean on the
people around you um
you can be both the leader of a film
and uh completely
um open and listen to everyone
around you and uh you can be both things
so
yeah saying i don't know is a really
really important and difficult it's
difficult to say especially
especially early in your career when
there's a certain pressure that
you feel to have answers and to be
confident
um we are almost out of time we're
almost out of time there's a question
here about
posted uh mido has a question for you
dave about the poster design for the
rental
and for you sean for the poster for
martha martin marlene can you talk a
little bit about
those concepts yes so
the the poster is tricky i mean i'm so
happy where we landed with the poster
but
i guess the thought process when we were
conceiving it was
all right my movie is not
a traditional horror movie it's there's
not jump scares every few minutes it's
not you're not going to be
it's just not it's not that typical
slasher movie
uh a lot of it really is this um this
tense relationship drama
that then kind of evolves into more of a
thriller and so we're like how do we
capture that with a poster how do we
capture that tone
and so i feel like we landed on
something
that um just like immediately
when you see it you're like all right i
feel a little off i feel
elements of like this is like it's kind
of scary but at the same time
hopefully a little bit artful and
um i don't know where i'm going with
this sean you go
i mean i honestly it's hard to remember
with martha it was a long time ago um
i think what it was was was there's a
lot of talk about the name
and obviously it's hard to remember all
her names
uh so we were trying to look for an
image
and i think just the m image was what um
was discussed as a way to you know
uh yeah just create like a symbol for
the movie and to put
um lizzie's face in that uh i think that
was
it was it was kind of that that simple
um
and with the nest uh similarly just a
simple approach like we looked at lots
of designs and
different things but at the end of the
day it came down to
uh just this couple in their
environments
and that seemed
like the simplest best way to go
i i feel like i i want to end this by
saying
because i feel like i haven't talked
about the nest as much as i want to
the nest is so fucking good i just i
just watched it again for the second
time
and it's giving me chills even just
talking about it right now like
it's just sean is making movies that no
one else is making
and he's just making these like very
very
nuanced intelligent movies for adults
and it's just watching it again the
second time and seeing how
every tiny decision it means something
and it's all adding
up in this way that you're not even
conscious of until the end and you're
just like oh my god
and i just want to like say as much as i
love and adore martha the nest is right
up there
and i just i'm excited for people to see
it
thanks dave yeah so um we are out of
time
my last question for both of you so
everyone that does these is
we just would like to hear your pandemic
picks
for people watching what should they
check out can be something old new
classic hidden gem movie tv
i can actually we've been we've been
writing down everything we've been
watching so i can just kind of list off
uh all right the most recent things
we've watched uh
the witches video drone sorry to bother
you
the thing paper moon badlands i may
destroy you
uh true romance i'm thinking of ending
things truman show
moon karate kid gremlins american movie
the documentary
good list i think the moon is one of my
favorite movies
so it's fantastic did you say moon
yeah it's perfect for pandemic
quarantine movie totally
yeah yeah um
yeah i mean i i have i think my favorite
uh
my favorite news show this year as i may
destroy you
absolutely loved it uh my favorite
ongoing show is better things
um i've watched it oh i haven't watched
the new season twice but i've watched it
all twice
uh i just think it's the most beautiful
portrayal of family life day to day and
every
every episode feels like its own short
film in a way i mean it's so inventive
and
it's just my favorite year after year um
but the other thing we've done that's
kind of crazy this year is we've watched
we've rewatched all of er
so it's just two nights ago
all 15 seasons of er that we started in
january
because it's like one of my favorite
shows of all time what's what's the take
what's the main
takeaway after after watching it all in
that in one in just a short chunk of
time
i mean it's it's it's certainly a
network show
uh and falls victim to some you know
pretty generic moments but the overall
heart of the show is so incredible
there's so much good acting uh martini
is like
one of my favorite actors of all time
and her
her her performance in the show is just
one of my favorites
and um and there's there's some like
amazing gem episodes like tarantino
directed an episode in the first season
oh wow just fun and so there's just
all these great great little discoveries
away
um some great cameos you know you see
some
young actors having these one-on-ones
and it was just it was really
it was really great to go back and and
watch the whole thing which is
insane because it's 15 seasons but can
you really
can you really feel the seeds of uh
clooney's hunkiness
oh for sure yeah
the seeds of his hokiness
my picks would be to go way back for
everyone and check out
martha marcy mae marlene on hbo max it's
there right now and for dave to check
out all his shorts
on funny or die great examples of
getting in and out
as quickly and as efficiently as
possible right or in the case of one of
them in out in and out in out and then
shout out sure good way to play it
but uh yeah thank you guys for doing
this it's been a pleasure to have you
here on the coffee talks um i hope
you'll come back
and do something with us in person next
time
absolutely that was that was really fun
paul and sean always a pleasure man and
thank you for everything dude
yeah yeah you both stay safe
sean dave thank you so much